welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka that spoiler
guy from YouTube and this video are
breaking down marbles Avengers
Crystal Dynamics hosted a big live
stream yesterday that went over the
entire project and throughout this video
we're going to be discussing everything
you need to know about it this video is
gonna contain what the gameplay is like
the story the potential Spider Man
connection and a lot more I've compiled
everything from entertainment website
inverse to the war table yesterday two
compilations trailers leaks and more to
give you all the info on the title that
I can now because of this there may be
some spoilers here so you don't anything
roomed that I highly recommend that you
turn off now make sure you subscribe to
the channel for videos like this every
day
and please Hulk smash that like button
if you enjoy the breakdown without the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into Marvel's Avengers ok so
firstly the game was originally set to
release on May the 15th however due to
the pandemic causing delays it's been
pushed back to September 4 to 2020
I actually pre-ordered it along with
some of the Funko's from the game and
they arrived a couple of weeks ago which
sucked because I was like oh yeah I
could have been playing this by now now
though this day is set to be and stone
by the studio actually caught remember a
game title in recent memory that I've
been looking forward to which hasn't
been delayed several times so with
everything going on I'm not gonna hold
my breath but September 4th is
apparently going to be the release date
that being said the title was announced
back in January 2017 and now that feels
like a lifetime ago did does show that
they've had a lot of time to work on it
the release is a result of a pairing
between Marvel and Square Enix and
according to inverse it will be the
first of many games that result from
their partnership so we may be getting
an MCU s game lineup that could result
in a scene titles for the Avengers
Fantastic Four x-men and many more it's
an exciting time to be a Marvel fan but
one question remains in regards to the
universe that is will Sony Spider Man on
PlayStation 4 be connected to the game
well the short answer is we don't know
I can actually see a similar sort of
situation to what we have in the movies
right now Sony passing their boy back
and forth between the studios has
allowed him to appear in multiple MCU
movies whilst they also develop their
own properties and in the recent deal
that was struck up between the pair it
makes sense that things like this would
be included across multiple forms of
media though different Studios are
behind the development of the games
there is room to collab with one another
and I think insomniac would probably
love to have the Crystal Dynamics heroes
in their games and vice-versa
during spider-man when you visit the
Avengers tower Peter even remarks that
the group are on the west coast and the
fact that the Avengers game takes place
there initially shows indeed that they
could have a shared universe I'm just
hoping that this is the case but it
makes sense to have the characters cross
over if they're planning on building a
game universe that rivals the MCU the
upcoming Miles Morales spider-man game
should hopefully shed more light on this
and it's due to release at the end of
the air on PlayStation 5 so keep your
eyes peeled now as for the story it's
gonna be very player focused and it will
take place in the near future starting
off at an Avengers themed celebration in
San Francisco this is known as a day and
now it begins all sunshine and rainbows
an attack on the Golden Gate Bridge
forces the heroes to avenge the avenge
the bridge is that the catchphrase
nevermind now the group go and head down
to it which is where the gameplay of
them on the bridge predominantly takes
place this was shown quite recently and
the 19 minute extravaganza really gives
you a good idea of how the game is going
to play and how jumping back and forth
between characters will play out now
whilst all of this is happening on the
bridge Captain America journeys to a
Helicarrier
which is where he fights off the bad
guys who are trying to gain an
experimental energy source the
Helicarrier explodes and cap is
seemingly killed during the blast this
even leads to a statue of him being
erected and a couple of weeks ago you
might have noticed it kicking off on
Twitter because Crystal Dynamics tweeted
out a picture of this whilst in real
life statues were being torn down in
America
yikes I don't think they meant anything
behind it it was just bad timing but
naturally you know this is 2020 and the
didn't take it too kindly anyway during
this attack Terrigen mist is also
sprayed over the Crowder a day and if
you're not fully up to speed with the
comics then this is basically the thing
that turns humans into Inhumans some die
when breathing in the gas some gain
special powers and others become failed
youtubers that report on Avengers games
anyway do do it all being one big
disaster the Avengers go into hiding it
turns out that the attack was set up to
look like they were the ones that
carried it out and thus they've been
outlawed I mean they saved the world
hundreds of times but maybe just give
them the benefit of the doubt once no
okay then now this is mainly because
Bruce Banner testifies against them
saying that they're a danger everyone is
also basically scared of Inhumans
because they've wrecked society and thus
heroes in general are hated it's solved
like the x-men plastic and it's clear
that they're taking certain elements
from that now dr. George Tarleton ends
up using the fear of the Inhumans to
weaponize his cruel desires and slowly
he becomes MODOK Crystal Dynamics have
created an Avengers level threatened the
villain I can't lie a really can't wait
to see what happens with him he's a very
unique character and yeah if you're a
fan of the comics you know that Mo Rocca
is a brilliant brilliant villain yes
later MS Mobile and it's a plan by Amon
MODOK in which they want to take over
the world and wipe out all the
metahumans to the public they've said
that they possess a cure for the
Inhumans that will create on a day but
of course it's actually something far
worse now throughout the game you'll be
playing as Ms marvel and the rest of the
Avengers as you bring their plans to
light and win back the favor of the
public now you will mostly be in the
shoes of Miss Marvel early on which when
this was announced did annoy a lot of
people but Crystal Dynamics have assured
us that they will be switching things up
that Bertha you get into the game the
presentation actually showed a mission
called once an Avenger and which the
player steps into the shoes of Thor he
also wears a name badge that says D
Blake and fans of marble will recognize
her this is Donald Blake the host
identity that Odin created for the god
of thunder to inhabit on earth it looked
like an awesome showdown and the
gameplay really makes you feel like an
Avenger
shout-outs IGN it was revealed by the
end that this was actually the
Helicarrier scene that you might have
seen in the first trailer for the game
and it looks like a great hero mission
as for the rest of the story the
avengers sort of go back and forth with
one another and it looks like we're
gonna be getting a sort of civil war a
snake from the - story trailer we saw
Hulk vs Iron Man is going down and I
swear if we get a Hulk Buster scene I'm
gonna lose it we do see the Hulk buster
at one point in the trailer so yeah
please make them fight make them fight
make them fight now that's pretty much
all of the plot points we know so far
but there will be more storylines
available as the studio are planning to
release free dlc and additional
characters to accompany the group
hawkeye is rumoured to be one of them so
yeah plenty to look forward to in
addition to this confirmed characters
are Hank Pym aka ant-man the abomination
taskmaster
Captain Marvel dumb-dumb Duggan Maria
Hill and Nick Fury you also have a
Helicarrier that is your BAE's known as
the Chimera Neill upgrader as you play
through the game I imagine that there'll
be a lot more added to it as the game
comes around but the lineup is looking
very solid right now now as for the
gameplay there's a lot to talk about and
the presentation was packed with a lot
of info on how it will be each character
controls differently the amount of
customization options available is
insane you can really make the
characters your own and there are
several upgrade trees special abilities
to unlock and lots of directions to take
your team in combat and movement wise I
would say it looks like it plays a lot
like God of War which is fitting as that
sort of felt like a Thor game with the
whole throwing your axe thing however
it's far more diverse in that you can
completely pile through people with the
Hulk or shoot from afar and dodge things
with Iron Man and Black Widow
there really is a lot to do in it and
it's heavily gear and loot focused it
kind of reminds me of injustice with how
you upgrade the characters but there is
a lot to do you can also play in either
co-op or single-player modes the former
of which will grant you access to
warzone missions that allow heroes to
team up and do assists so just like the
movies you can use Thor to electrify
Iron Man's armor and it's gonna be
interesting to see
want different combinations you can pull
off now before we get into the rest of
the video I just wanna let you know
we're giving away a free copy of the MCU
infinity Saga box set to one random
subscriber all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on the news in the
comments section below the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of July
and this I'll be shipped out from the
interval get surprised so best of luck
to everyone who takes part now as for
how the game looks I actually think it
looks really solid now I was in the
livestream and I did see a lot of people
saying it looks like a mobile game and
though I don't think it's last of us 2
levels graphics wise I still think it
looks pretty good now I'm guessing
graphics won't improve that much as they
don't have much time to do in order to
get ready for September and though it
doesn't look crazy crazy
it still looks crazy crazy to me there's
a lot of effects going on so I'm
guessing they had to tone things down in
order to stop the fan on your console
going crazy because playing the last of
us - yeah my ps4 I could just tell it
wasn't having a good time it's pretty
much completely the entire game now the
studio are also doing something cool -
as if you buy the game on ps4 you'll
automatically get it free on PS 5 so I
definitely think it's worth getting
early on and then you can go back and
play it when the PS 5 comes out anyway
that's all the things we know so far and
obviously I'm very hyped for September
obviously I'd loved hear your thoughts
on the game and if you're excited for it
too comment below and let me know and if
you enjoyed this video then please drop
a thumbs up and also a huge thank you to
everyone who voted in yesterday's poll
to get this video selected for today's
topic if you want to support the channel
from its little is 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early we're gonna come chat to us after
the show either follow us at heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below those are the best
ways to Cuban a date with us and thanks
very much for watching till the end of
the video
I've been definition you've been the
best now see you next time take care
peace up
you
[Music]